the jurgen experience so how does how
did this work without naming names you
don't know or if you want to name names
look here's the thing the reason why i
haven't named the streamer and people
have said a bunch of things because like
the guy there is a good guy and he
fought for it but people have bosses
and
sometimes you have to do what the boss
says right you know what was the
scenario well i sold a special we had it
ready to go
before even before covered we had did
you did you sell it before you filmed it
yes okay yeah so you had a deal yep had
a deal and everything ready to go did
they go they saw me live
yes wow okay so they bought it they go
we like it this is great at the show you
were at
okay
we're good everything's good to go
basically
the chappelle trans thing happens and
they freak out yeah
culture changed
they freaked the [ __ ] out
i go i'm not cutting these and they
start saying these like weird like
corporate terms like
you know we don't want any punching down
which is like really the most like
bigoted [ __ ] way of looking at
something like you have to look at
yourself higher and above another person
and like i get it you see a white guy on
stage making fun of every different
culture and person like i'm calling i'm
[ __ ] making fun of a somali dude i'm
making fun of women i'm making fun of
like whoever is making mexicans myself
too though a lot exactly i'm teasing me
constantly everybody gets these jokes
that's the ethos yeah you've been at the
show you understand what it is and all
these people they're coming for that
they want to be part of it because they
recognize i don't [ __ ] hate these
people i'm actually curious i don't like
dissecting comedy like that too much to
other people like with the comics i'll
do it but like i'm curious in your
culture and i want to learn about it and
like i understand that like as an
outsider maybe i have some cool
observations that like you know but you
didn't know other people saw right and
then like you get to see that kind of
get exposed and and people really like
that they like being represented by it i
make a joke about albanians the [ __ ]
albanian community shares it like crazy
yeah you know it's just like it's a
really cool thing that happened yeah and
and we had this great [ __ ] thing at
these live shows where everybody walks
in the door and they just they turn off
the i'm offended by everything or
whatever the world is outside and it
becomes like
i don't know what the
i don't even know what to compare to but
it kind of becomes like remember when
you're riding the bus to school
yes and it's like yo we're all on the
bus bro yeah everybody's getting made
fun of and you're gonna get some [ __ ]
thrown in the back of your head and then
you're gonna clap back at that
[ __ ] for having a big nose and
he's gonna clap back at you and this
girl's got red hair we're [ __ ]
lighting her up and it was just the best
30 minutes on the way to school right
and it's like we've made that and it
exists and it happens and all this
[ __ ] outreach [ __ ] is [ __ ] and
you saw it in the room it's beautiful
well the people that were there are the
people that seek out that kind of humor
yes that is that's the thing it's like
is it okay to seek out that kind of
humor now if you don't like that kind of
humor
don't [ __ ] watch it and this is the
[ __ ] this is the crazy thing about it
because i understand some what the the
network wants like take it down and i'm
[ __ ] grateful i was even able to buy
it back okay that's awesome i put it out
myself right and i put out on my website
and i'm only putting out for [ __ ] two
weeks okay there's a two-week [ __ ]
window where you can buy it it stops i
think august 1st or july 31st the last
day
i don't know but whatever the [ __ ] i
want interesting because i own it
that's what i'm saying why'd you decide
two weeks though urgency
i saw these amazing comics put specials
up on like a platform like netflix and
it just like it's a fart in the wind
like people go i'll get to it eventually
oh it's there forever i'll get to it
so much and there's no urgency i wanted
a [ __ ] pay-per-view event like
there's a reason i had [ __ ] bruce and
you connected me so thank you so much
for that but like bruce did the intro
yeah which bruce buffer's the man bruce
is the [ __ ] dude let me tell you
something about bruce like and michael
irvin has this as well
michael irvin he hit a term for it man i
forget the [ __ ] name for it but like
he's like i'm uh i'm a hundred percenter
i go what's that mean he goes whatever
i'm doing
it's a hundred percent
bruce is a hundred percenter yeah
whatever if
he could have been easy he could have
had [ __ ] note cards and read off the
note cards
he he even said to us he goes let me
give it another shot and then [ __ ]
tour the roof
refresh this and do it from the top oh
this [ __ ] is crazy
[Applause]
put the headphones on
this is the moment you've all been
waiting for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
new york city he is the
reigning
the fanduel
undisputed
heavyweight
champion of the world
the one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's like a tomato he's as red as a
tomato at the end he's the best he
doesn't have to do it of course he does
but he's a hundred percent he's all in i
mean that's he's the best announcer of
all time ever ever and it's like
he came through he [ __ ] did it and
then and i mean honestly kind of cool
story the song that plays afterwards is
by a musician named russ who is like the
ultimate [ __ ] indie dude and he's the
reason i posted [ __ ] on youtube
he said in an interview that he wasn't
getting attraction so he said [ __ ] and
i'm going to put out a song a week
every week i'm gonna put out a song and
i'm just gonna get better at this and
keep on putting it out and i was like
[ __ ] i'm not working hard enough if this
guy could put out a song a week i'm
gonna put out a clip a week
and i put out clip a week on [ __ ]
instagram and youtube for a year
and that changed everything so i hit him
up and i told him the [ __ ] story and
i was like dude it would be an honor if
we could have
you do a song and he gave us a [ __ ]
unreleased song
that's amazing to put on the thing so it
was that's dope that's dope too that he
was the inspiration and then he brought
it all around yeah and he's on your show
i don't know but yeah the [ __ ] the
thing with the jokes is like
i'm not editing [ __ ] jokes joe i
don't mind like you write a movie for me
tell me what the [ __ ] to say if i agree
to do it i'll [ __ ] do it but
i made this
and i'm so grateful for you for even
shining a light on what i was doing and
and creating this opportunity for me
like coming on this show for the first
time like not only changed my career but
i think it changed a lot of comics
career because they also started doing
the youtube stuff and instagram stuff
and it really like transformed
how comedy is is done now for a new
generation like literally it's like idea
and then platform and cosign
can can shift the [ __ ] industry dude
you